like mh370 ended in the southern Indian
Ocean madam Speaker we mourn all those
239 passengers and crew people want
answers to what's happened know
everyone's gonna want closure this is
still an attempt to search a very large
area this has a long way to go
three weeks after the disappearance of
flight mh370 and locating the missing
aircraft finally appears to be a step
nearer officials have shifted the search
area after receiving new information but
there's been no recovery of debris or
the planes black box flight recorder in
this program we look at the search
operation and whether the unanswered
questions of the Malaysian Airlines
flight can still be answered the Boeing
777 disappeared after leaving Kuala
lumper bound for Beijing on March the
8th 239 people who were on board the
hunt for the missing plane has become
one of the largest and most complex in
air aviation history and for the
families waiting for information it has
been a tortuous three weeks the new
information is based on continuing
analysis of radar data about the
aircraft's movement between the South
China Sea and the Strait of Malacca
before radar contact was lost this
continuing analysis indicates the plane
was traveling faster than was previously
estimated resulting in increased fuel
usage and reducing the possible distance
it traveled south into the Indian Ocean
the international investigative team
supporting the search continues their
analysis of the data this could result
in further refinement of the potential
flight path of mh370 radar data suggests
the plane flew faster than investigators
first thought when it was between the
South China Sea and the Malacca Strait
meaning it burnt more fuel reducing the
distance it could have traveled south to
account for that the search has been
moved 685 miles northeast of the
previous search areas the area covers
around a hundred and ninety eight
thousand square miles
the new search area is more favorable
with weather conditions around 1,100
miles from Perth closer than the
original areas by about 400 miles
meaning planes use less fuel getting
there and can search for longer we will
certainly get better time on scene we
started nearly 3,000 kilometres from
Perth so taken quite a lot off that and
now we will get you might recall we were
talking in terms of one to two hours on
scene and we're now doing much better
than that and the other benefit we get
from moving further north is the search
area has moved out of the roaring 40s
which creates very adverse weather
frequently I'm not sure that will get
perfect weather out there but it's
likely to be better more often than
we've seen in the past and we will see
what that does in terms of satellite
imagery when the retasking of satellite
starts to produce new material an
international flotilla of ships and
planes have been scouring the southern
Indian Ocean now their efforts are being
refocused with objects already spotted
in the new search area it's not clear
whether this is the first evidence of
debris from the plane but as David
Bowden explains the new search area has
put the investigation on a new course
let's just remind ourselves the plane of
course took off from Kuala lumper three
weeks ago and we know it pretty quickly
turned to the west and then move down
because we had radar in it now looks as
though some other radar is telling us
why it's gone down where we now think it
has done what's happened right so the
plane takes off and the primary military
raid on the area picks up the object it
can tell how high it flies how quickly
and in which direction which is data
they use right now then we got the MSR
satellite pings which allow us to
estimate the flying route and we know
now it's
Souths putting this data together
together with a fuel consumption of this
typical Boeing they figured out it's
probably gone down further north and
they had us estimated before okay so
that's how we got to the new search
areas Chris let's come to you tell us
where the first one was some 1500 miles
or so to the southwest of Perth and now
where the new one is 700 miles or so
north east of that and what the
significance is of moving from pretty
much close to the Antarctic to the coast
of Australia well the reason why the
first one was chosen was because
satellite photography showed lots of
objects floating there so that's the
first place you would look on that basis
it's moved because the data which Mischa
has described led people to think that
the plane had come down further north in
this area here that is of course is the
area where we think the plane came down
now because of the currents and the
winds and the time debris from the plane
coming down there could well have
drifted as far south as this in the
intervening areas could in fact be the
right search areas for different things
yes okay a little bit about the depth
here because that changes as well
doesn't it I mean the depth of the ocean
in the original search area was all the
way down to something like 8,000 meters
way way down though we thought perhaps
the plane was probably three an hour
4,000 meters as we move to the new area
that all comes up it's only two thousand
two kilometers down it's still a long
way but it's a complete game-changer
isn't it Chris to try and actually find
something at that depth yes because the
the crucial fact is is that the black
box you will be able to pick it up down
to about six kilometers and certainly it
at two kilometers it's the search area
straddles a feature called the the
broken plateau which is kind of a ridge
so the plane if it is down there
it may well have come to rest on top of
that Plateau and that search area
actually straddles the plateau just west
of another feature called the East
Indiaman Ridge which goes away to the
north so we're assuming here gentlemen
that they've moved the search here
because we think that's where the plane
actually went into the water and that's
probably where the black boxes that's
right because the black box is going to
be very heavy and is almost certainly
going to sink until now investigators
have only had satellite images of
potential debris in the sea hundreds of
tiny dots and a vast expanse of ocean to
scour at the Pierce airbase in Perth
Western Australia where the search has
been coordinated new equipment and
personnel are arriving skies James
Matthews is with the teams hoping to
find answers for the families of mh370 s
ill-fated passengers here at the Pierce
airbase from where the planes are
leaving to search the Indian Ocean
noting the atmosphere has inevitably
changed in the beginning people believed
in the data thinking I think there was a
natural expectation that there may well
be a quick result but as time has grown
so has the awareness that this may well
be a long-haul operation it changed the
mood drastically I think today and
certainly the sense of anticipation when
the search zone was shifted no less than
700 miles I think everybody got a sense
then that there's a fair degree a large
degree of feeling in the dark on this
particular operation the search for
missing mh370 appears to be making
progress but experts are warning they
still have a mountain to climb to put
together all the pieces of the jigsaw in
this mystery this is still an attempt to
search a very large area and for surface
debris which will give us an indication
of where the the main aircraft wreckage
is likely to be this has a long way to
go
in part two we examine why it's taken
this long to close in on the wreckage of
missing flight mh370 and why lessons
within the industry simply haven't been
learnt
like mh370 ended in the southern Indian
Ocean madam Speaker we mourn all those
239 passengers and crew people want
answers to what's happened know
everyone's gonna want closure this is
still an attempt to search a very large
area this has a long way to go
new calculations suggest flight mh370
was traveling faster than first thought
meaning it ran out of fuel earlier
that's shifted the search almost 700
miles northeast closer to the Australian
coast but why wasn't the plane carrying
specialist equipment making it easier to
track
Sky News has been examining documents
drawn up after an Air France airliner
came down in the Atlantic in 2009 there
were several recommendations for the
airline industry including extending
blackbox battery life but many airlines
including Malaysian haven't put them
into practice instead of 30 days let's
make them 90 days and that is practical
actually this document which was printed
in 2010 said that general installations
of 90 day batteries which are feasible
they can be made they are being made
should start from 2011 changing the
frequency the black box transmits that
would also help the search for a missing
plane they're set at 37 point 5
kilohertz and the listening devices the
receivers are tuned exactly to that
frequency the problem with that
frequency is only gives you a range
effective range listening rain
detectable range of probably about less
than 2,000 meters on Air France that was
calculated precisely to be 1760 meters
if you reduce that frequency the lower
the frequency the greater the range
you go from a 37 point 5 kilohertz to
say 8 point 8 killer it's that was
recommended I think that would increase
the range to probably over 10,000 meters
so that's a 5 times increase in your
detectable range there were other simple
cheap and effective changes recommended
four years ago continuous transmission
of the basic airplane parameters this is
through eight cars for example so
second-by-second we know all the data
about that plane including its position
triggered transmission of the flight
data say there's a catastrophic incident
it's like pushing a mayday on ships
ships have made a buttons literally if
you have a problem and all you can do in
one second is not even pick up your ad
but push a button that sends out a
signal that that ships in trouble you
could also do the same thing either with
a button or automatically weather an
hour
crafts and then finally deployable
recorders these cockpit voice recorders
and flight data recorders are now
sitting at the bottom of the ocean three
thousand four thousand meters deep what
if when the plane crashed they separated
from the aircraft and floated and then
could be recovered
sadly you see how slow things happen
because on this Malaysian plane none of
these things have been implemented
investigators have only 10 days before
the black box's battery dies the search
is a highly specialized skilled
operation Sky's Amanda Walker has more
on the underwater technology that will
be deployed if anything can find flight
mh370 s black box it's this the
state-of-the-art hydrophone deployed
with the US Navy to help solve the
agonizing mystery this is the crucial
noise that everyone wants it to detect
the pings emitted by a black box we are
very optimistic that the equipment can
do the work it just depends on how much
time we have to do it
bad weather makes the operation go much
much longer the deaths should not be a
problem here the topography should not
be a problem it can track the pings made
by a data recorder from up to around 4
miles underwater flight mh370 s pings
are expected to fall silent in around
two weeks time the pinger has
approximately a 30 day battery life it's
like if you have a flashlight you keep
it on it'll slowly get dimmer and dimmer
until it wouldn't come on anymore it's
the same with the pinger
but if time does run out all might not
be lost Phoenix International assisted
with the recovery effort of the Air
France plane that went down in the
Atlantic five years ago the black box
ping was never heard but this equipment
helped them find it anyway this remotely
operated vehicle can function up to four
miles down it's equipped with light
sonar and cameras and it's those arms
that would ultimately recover a black
box but no one is doubting the Mammoth's
scale of this task the authorities know
how many hopes are pinned to this
technology and the chance that it could
lead to at least some answers but so
many are so desperately seeking the
question of why the aircraft went down
is still unanswered and may prove as
challenging as the search early
suspicion fell on the flights captain
53 year old Zachary Ahmed Shah he was an
experienced pilot with more than
eighteen and a half thousand flying
hours under his belt
the first officer was Fariq Abdul Hameed
he's 27 years old and joined Malaysia
Airlines in 2007 he was fairly new to
this model of aircraft a Boeing 777-200
CCTV shows the two men going through
security on their way to board the
flight that evening we are told they did
not specifically request to fly together
it's not even known if they knew each
other
police have searched their homes talking
to friends and neighbors they found this
simulator in captain zaharie's house
investigators say that some data on it
had been deleted attention then turned
from the pilots to the passengers could
the flight manifest hold answers
investigators are scrutinizing every
name on it three weeks after the planes
disappearance and we're learning more
about the men women and children who
were on board this flight people we were
told this week who have no chance of
survival Chandrika Sharma was heading to
Mongolia via Beijing to attend a United
Nations meeting on food and agriculture
the youngest passenger on the flight was
two years old the oldest 76 seven of the
passengers were under the age of five
twenty-six-year-old un chow was
originally from mongolia he moved to
study business at whole University in
England he was travelling to see his
girlfriend
Mukesh Mukherjee and his wife Xiao Mao
Mao had been on a beach holiday together
in Vietnam their two young sons were
waiting for them at home 15 different
nationalities were flying to Beijing
that night amongst them 153 were from
China 38 from Malaysia 5 Indians four
French 3 from the US two Iranian zhan
board became initial suspects but now
seemed to have been ruled out
thirty-five-year-old Xiuquan was a
stuntman who was due to work on a new
series for Netflix in Malaysia next week
he was on his way to Beijing to see his
two young children Bob and Cathy Lawton
were from Springfield Lakes in Australia
they have three daughters they are
described as doting grandparents Paul
weeks was a mechanical engineer
he left his wedding ring and watched
behind at home when he travelled to
Mongolia for work
Hadrian wore trellis on the right was 17
jyan on the left 18 they were on their
way to school in Beijing families of the
Chinese passengers accused Malaysian
Airlines of withholding information and
marched on the Malaysian Embassy in the
Chinese capital there has been huge
tension between the Chinese relatives
and the airline I have children I have
brothers I have family members and I can
imagine what they're going through but I
just want to say to the Chinese families
that it's not just them that lost or
looking for those members nations also
have lost family members
at every turn the mystery of mh370 has
defied simple explanation the hope for
the search crews at work over the vast
expanses of the Indian Ocean is that
they can finally locate the lost plane
providing answers for those who simply
don't understand why so many questions
remain unanswered three weeks on no
matter what has been thrown and labeled
at us history will judges as a country
that has been very responsible
we have corroborated any evidence that
we have received we have made sure that
no stones unturned notwithstanding many
speculation in the early stages in the
Southeast Asian or black estates or in
the social media we have not distracted
from our main focus which is to identify
the plane
you